cette fois c'est du sérieux oubliez le
canular et les idées farfelues de 2008
david l'anneau du grès avec son
inséparable chapeau a bien déposé
officiellement sa liste ce matin une
liste qui se veut apolitique 59 non
venue de la société civile des
commerçants avocat la plupart ont moins
de 45 ans avec l'ambition de conjuguer
le verbe dijonnais avec ses électeurs
il fallait y aller puisque toute façon
on a senti une émulation de la
population dijonnaise et comme quoi il y
avait vraiment une
une réelle attente en fait une liste
complètement apolitique issue
complètement la société civile ce qui
est quelque chose qui sera unique à
dijon puisque toutes les autres listes
sont encartés d'un parti politique
lui qui voulait climatisé la ville où
faire venir la coupe du monde de surf
sur le lac kir s'est un peu assagie son
principal credo dynamiser le
centre-ville en rasant notamment le
centre dauphine ou en reverdissant la
rue de la liberté
mais il garde une touche de provocation
en voulant transformer l'église
saint-philippe et en discothèque ou
ramener la tour eiffel à dijon
c'est loufoque mais derrière y'a quand
même toujours une idée sérieuse pareil
quand je dis que je rasais son dauphine
d'ailleurs des idées qui sont non
sérieuse pour vous mais qui finalement
le sont quand même puisque le candidat
françois rebsamen sérieux reprend des
idées du candidat non sérieux donc qu'il
n'y a pas que celle ci d'ailleurs là le
fait de voir faire une patinoire dont
l'annoncé est longtemps il veut lancer
une marque la marque dijon ça fait six
mois qu'on avait fait un communiqué de
presse à dessus pour lancer le made in
dijon donc finalement le candidat non
sérieux à des idées qui intéressent et
candidat sérieux
crédité de 5% dans un sondage david
l'anneau du grès sera-t-il vraiment pris
au sérieux par les électeurs il sera en
tout cas le trublion poil à gratter de
cette campagne